now that Apple's 15-inch M2 MacBook Air
is finally here we can see how it
compares to the windows competition so
we have one of the lightest and thinnest
Windows laptops out there the LG gram
15. so in this video we're going to
compare everything including the designs
portability weights keyboards track pads
displays performance and more to see
which one is the better one to go with
because they're both Seventeen hundred
dollars and they both have 16 gigs of
RAM and 512 gigs of SSD let's get right
into it now both of these are fully
charged so I'm going to unplug them and
we are going to do a battery life test
to see how the 15-inch MacBook Air
compares to the LG now in terms of
thickness even though this is a super
thin Windows laptop the MacBook Air is
so much thinner just look at the
difference right here it's massive and
if I spin it around even on the thinnest
part of the LG gram the Mac book air is
still thinner now in terms of the actual
footprint they're very similar but you
could see that the MacBook Air does
stick out a little bit so it's a little
bit taller this way but if I spin it
around you can see that the LG gram does
stick out so it's a little bit longer
now in terms of the weight the LG gram
is insanely light
2.13 pounds compared to 3.3 but honestly
holding them in your hands it's not that
big of a deal I would prefer the extra
weight just for the extra solidness and
what I mean by that is this check this
out I'm pushing hard on the MacBook and
it's holding up pretty well but check
out the amount of flex on the LG the
whole thing is caving in it's like
almost Hollow in the display section and
then even further going over to the
keyboards you can see there's a little
bit of flex on the MacBook Air but over
here it almost seems like it's gonna
cave in or something's gonna break and
as far as the displays the MacBook is
really solid I'm trying lines of Wiggle
the display but it's literally just
moving the whole thing over here
look at that flex but the big benefit on
the LG gram is that it's packed with a
bunch of ports over here on the left
side you can see we have HDMI we have
Thunderbolt 4 USBC and a headphone jack
and then we got two additional USB A's
and a Micro SD card slot so tons of
ports on the LG gram whereas on the 15
inch MacBook gear we literally only have
macsafe two Thunderbolt 4S and a
headphone jack that is all so you're
pretty limited and in terms of display
support you can only run One external
display with the MacBook while you could
do three on the LG gram so that's pretty
nice now another thing I really like
with the LG gram is that it supports
Windows hello login so you can see right
here there you go it scanned my face I'm
in no extra steps needed whereas with
the 15 inch air you have to use the
touch ID sensor to log in and now before
I move on to the displays let's talk
about the keyboards and the trash pads
honestly the keyboard on the LG gram is
really really good it got a lot of key
travel very tactile this feels like an
excellent excellent keyboard now on the
MacBook
it's almost there it's not enough travel
a little bit less than the LG gram it
still feels really good but I'd have to
give the keyboard over to the LG it just
feels amazing but as far as the track
pad this is where it gets a little bit
different because the LG uses the
traditional diving board trackpad design
which honestly I can't stand it's
horrible because at the bottom it's easy
to click just barely any effort but at
the top and near the middle gets harder
almost impossible at the very top
whereas Apple's magic Trackpad is
absolutely amazing you have awesome
gesture support and you get an even
clicking feel everywhere top bottom
middle it's perfect and it's actually
fully customizable so you can make it
easier to click and customize everything
including the gestures and the feedback
and now let's compare this speaker
quality as you might know Apple put a
huge focus on the speakers with a brand
new six speaker system compared to the
regular LG speaker so I have them both
maxed out as you can see right here so
let's listen
[Music]
foreign
oh my goodness guys I cannot believe it
the LG sells like a tin can it is
horrible this should be a crime in 2023
for 1700 the same price of the MacBook
gear it sounds terrible there's no mids
no bass it's just a little scratchy
little speaker in there compared to an
absolutely amazing speaker system you
have bass you have mids sharp highs it
sounds amazing compared to this thing
you know what guys it sounds so bad I
have to pull up my phone and compare
this to my phone check this out
that's the LG
[Music]
soon
okay
[Music]
the iPhone has more bass than this
laptop it's insane and now let's compare
the webcams and the microphones this is
the 15 inch MacBook Air let me know how
this looks and sounds compared to the LG
gram 15 and right away I could actually
see differences on the screen itself but
you guys will hear the microphone so
comment down below which one sounds
better now before I move on if you've
been wondering what this thing has been
around my neck well it is the cool fi3
wearable air conditioner from our
sponsor Taurus it is jam-packed with
technology including graphene cooling
which can cool you down by 37 degrees
and if you don't believe me check out
all of the amazing reviews online not
only does it cool but it also heats up
which is what I was just doing right now
it actually has two zones on the sides
right here and on the back right here
you can see there's seven air Outlets
four right here and two in the back and
the awesome thing is that it has a
really ergonomic design which fits a lot
of different neck sizes very lightweight
for all the stuff that's jam-packed into
it right here on the right side it has a
couple of buttons power and mode so you
can kind of cycle through the strength
of the cooling or just the fan or the
heating that you want it's already cold
right now but if I turn it into the
highest mode and my neck is literally
freezing right now now this thing will
last up to 18 hours but even if you put
it in the craziest AC and fan mode it'll
still last two hours which is more than
long enough to do something like mow the
lawn in the extreme heat now the really
cool thing is that it comes with this
zip up hard case in the box and this
really nice angled charging cable so you
basically plug it in and when you put it
on it's out of your way and you can even
charge it while you use it with a
battery bank that you just put into your
back pocket and in terms of the actual
charging speed it'll go up to 80 percent
in one hour and 20 minutes or 100 in
three hours one thing that this will be
perfect for is for people who work
outside like construction workers put
this on and you'll be fine and nice and
cool in the Heat and then on the flip
side you could use it in heating mode
for the winter you're shoveling the snow
outside this will keep you warm and they
even have their coolify app you can heat
just the back or all of it or just the
sides going through the levels of
heating cooling and just fan mode so
honestly guys this thing has blown away
our expectations so check it out using
the link in the description below and
now let's get into comparing the display
quality now on this LG gram we have a
15.6 inch display which is actually OLED
and low reflectivity because it's a
matte display but it's only 1080p which
on a 15.6 inch display you could
definitely tell it is nowhere near as
sharp as the 15.3 inch MacBook Air which
is actually 2.8 K resolution so very
very sharp now in terms of the
brightness of the displays the LG gram
is only 350 nits compared to 500 on the
15-inch MacBook Air so it is quite a bit
brighter and now comparing the display
quality let's run LG's own OLED test on
an LG OLED display compared to the
MacBook display which is by the way LCD
and oh my goodness right here the
MacBook actually looks a lot better the
blacks look deeper deeper than the
actual OLED because of the actual matte
coating which is anti-reflectivity it
makes it look gray and not black which
man the 15 inch looks so much better and
the colors they pop so much more and now
let's get into performance and I don't
to mention that we are running on
battery on both of these and the LG is
set to best performance mode Let's first
do an SSD speed test using Crystal
dismark whoa guys I'm running just the
SSD speed test
and I can actually hear the fan running
on the LG gram which by the way the 15
inch is completely fanless so it's
silent I can't believe it's running and
wow that SSD is fast running PCI Express
4 speeds on the LG 7 000 megabytes per
second read that's over twice as fast as
the 15 inch MacBook Air and the right is
also quite a bit faster as well and now
let's run geekbench 6 we have the M2
Chip over here with 16 gigs of RAM and
for the LG we also have 16 gigs of RAM
but we have the Intel 13th gen i7
1360p which is the performance version
not the U so it should be really fast so
let's run this and wow that is actually
very impressive especially unplugged for
a Windows laptop
9063 points compared to 99.72 that makes
the 15 inch MacBook Air 10 faster in
multi-core and 12 faster into terms of
single core not that far off and now as
far as Graphics we have 3D Marks
Wildlife extreme unlimited test running
on both of these to test the graphics
performance and oh my goodness guys we
have our results and I am so happy that
Apple ditched Intel because if they
didn't they would have had this
performance in this MacBook Air check
this out the LG got 15.34 FPS compared
to
41.2 that's 2.7 times faster Graphics in
this test absolutely blows it away and
now let's run cinebench which is a CPU
stress test now we know that the 15 inch
had 10 percent faster multi-core
performance in terms of geekbench but
this should give us different results
and wow this is actually impressive the
LG gram improved by quite a bit 84.99
points compared to 86.50 now the 15 inch
is only 2 percent faster but because
it's fanless it actually does thermal
throttle a bit after 10 to 15 minutes
and it'll go down to 7 500 while the LG
should sustain this level of performance
so it's very impressive and now let's go
ahead and test web-based apps this is
web design this is a project provided to
us by 500 designs based out of
California a really awesome web design
company the first part of the test is to
zoom in really close and see how fast it
loads and responds so it looks like it
took a few seconds there and then on the
15 inch MacBook
yep also loaded just about the same
speed and that makes sense because the
CPU performance is very similar but now
let's do an export test exporting these
12 selected layers on each okay that was
really weird the MacBook took a minute
and 48 seconds but the LG gram took only
14 that doesn't make sense maybe it's
because they're doing a new kind of
method where it kind of exports as it
downloads the images maybe it did that
on this one whereas it's not on Chrome
on Mac OS I'm not sure so maybe we're
gonna have to do some sort of an update
and change to see what's going on so
because it didn't work let's actually
run speedometer 2.1 to test web app
performance a different way and there
you go those are some different results
we have 328 runs per minute on the LG
466 on the Macbook so 42 faster web
browsing performance both of them on
Chrome and now let's get into photo
editing with Lightroom classic the this
right here is a project with 50 42
megapixel raw images so let's export
them and see the times bam wow the
15-inch MacBook Air finished in a minute
and 19 seconds and the LG is still going
that's surprising because in cinebench
they were in neck and neck almost the
same score but the MacBook is just
killing it right now and there you go
the LG finish two minutes and five
seconds that's almost an extra minute
compared to the 15 inch MacBook Air
that's probably because of the unified
memory architecture with the whole chip
on one package and probably the graphics
performance as well so definitely faster
on the MacBook and now let's test some
video editing with DaVinci Resolve
studio right here we have a 4K 8-bit H
EVC project so let's run it on both and
see the performance it looks like both
of them are running it at full 24 FPS so
this amount of graphics performance is
just enough for some something like this
and now let's go ahead and Export this
by the way we're using Intel's newest
quick sync encoders compared to Apple's
M2 encoders and wow the M2 air is flying
88 FPS for this export compared to only
19 for the LG gram it's going at a pace
of over four times faster right now and
wow guys this is insane the 15 inch
finish in a minute and 22 seconds guess
how long the LG took six minutes and 12
seconds that is absolutely insane
basically five times longer wow that is
a massive difference and it's all about
the real world performance because we
didn't see that difference when we
tested Wildlife extreme only in a test
like this is where we see a massive
massive difference and keep in mind the
M2 Chip also has prores codec encoders
as well which would absolutely
obliterate the LG gram and now with all
of that said and tested we've been
shooting for a while let's go ahead and
test the battery life and see what these
are at so let's see the LG has 62
percent battery life not bad and the
MacBook has
77 so you can see how much more life you
have with the MacBook with a better
display with a lot better resolution
basically over double the resolution and
still better battery life and now let me
finish off with my final conclusion and
thoughts well it looks like apple just
came out gunning and they just destroyed
the 15-inch laptop Market because at the
same price the MacBook is better on
basically every level quality design
displays trackpad especially performance
everything definitely the speakers
better than the LG at the same price
point I don't know why anybody would buy
this instead of a 15-inch MacBook Air it
is just night and day so hopefully you
enjoy this video let me know your own
thoughts down in the comment section
below and click that Circle above to
subscribe for more videos like this one
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
[Music]
thank you